HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
SEAN HANNITY IS NEXT.
♪
>> HI, WELCOME TO HANNITY
TONIGHT MARKS THE END OF YET
A MAJOR WEEK OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
TWO HISTORIC NEW TRADE
DEALS, A RECORD-SETTING
ECONOMY, MAJOR PROGRESS ON
THE BORDER WALL.
SAFETY, SECURITY, AND
PROSPERITY FOR ALL
AMERICANS, NOBODY CAN
DISPUTE ANY OF THIS.
NONE OF IT MATTERS TO
TODAY'S RADICALIZED
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT SUMMED
IT UP PERFECTLY DURING AN
EVENT WITH COLLEGE FOOTBALL
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP LSU.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JUST TOLD THE COACH WE
DON'T NORMALLY DO THIS BUT
I'M DOING IT FOR THIS TEAM.
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO COME
WITH ME TO THE OVAL OFFICE,
WE WILL TAKE PICTURES IN THE
OVAL.
IT'S A SPECIAL PLACE.
WE WILL TAKE PICTURES BEHIND
THE RESOLUTE DESK.
IT'S BEEN THERE A LONG TIME.
A LOT OF PRESIDENTS.
SOME GOOD, SOME NOT SO GOOD.
YOU HAVE GOT A GOOD ONE NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE TRYING
TO IMPEACH THE SON OF BITCH.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> Sean: DEMOCRATS KNOW THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE VINDICATED
AT THE END OF THE SENATE'S
TRIAL.
THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY ARE MORE INTERESTED IN
FINDING AN OUTLET FOR
PSYCHOTIC ANTI-TRUMP RAID.
HURTS THEM RUNNING IN 2020.
ON WEDNESDAY NANCY PELOSI
ALL SMILES, THERE SHE IS,
LITERALLY SIGNING OFF ON HER
B.S. PARTISAN IMPEACHMENT
ARTICLES.
HAPPENING OUT COMMEMORATIVE
GOLD PENS WITH HER AUTOGRAPH
ON THEM AND TAKING, WELL,
PICTURES WITH ANYBODY WHO
WANTED THEM.
IT WAS HER CROWNING AND ONLY
ACHIEVEMENT BASICALLY AS
HOUSE SPEAKER.
THAT VERY SAME DAY DEMOCRATS
TRIED TO DERAIL THE SENATE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL WITH A
LAST-MINUTE SMEAR CAMPAIGN
DISGUISED AS IMPORTANT NEW
EVIDENCE.
THE EXACT SAME TACTIC THEY
USED, REMEMBER, AGAINST
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
DID THE SAME THING.
NOW, BY THE WAY.
NEW EVIDENCE THAT JOE AND
HUNTER WERE INNOCENT AND
THAT THE PROSECUTOR THAT WAS
INVESTIGATING ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER WAS
CORRUPT.
OH, THAT'S NEW EVIDENCE?
OH, GREAT.
GLAD THEY DETERMINED ALL OF
THAT RIGHT BEFORE THEIR VERY
EYES AND THAT NIGHT THE LEFT
ANOINTED A BRAND NEW SAVIOR.
THIS IS MICHAEL AVENATTI 2.0
A MAN OUT ON BAIL CHARGED
WITH FELONY FINANCE FRAUD
HIDING GET THIS YOU CAN'T
MAKE IT UP A MILLION-DOLLAR
PAYMENT FROM THE COUNTRY OF
RUSSIA.
LIKE I SAID, AVENATTI 2.0.
254 APPEARANCES FOR AVENATTI
IN ONE YEAR.
JUST LIKE THEIR LOVE AFFAIR
WITH THE CURRENTLY
IMPRISONED ATTORNEY,
DEMOCRATS AND THE MOB ARE
WILLING TO OVERLOOK MASSIVE
CREDIBILITY ISSUES.
RUN WITH IT.
BECAUSE THAT GUY, YES, BEING
CHARGED WITH SERIOUS CRIMES,
LEV PARNAS FEEDS INTO
ANTI-TRUMP HYSTERIA.
SAME PEOPLE LIE TALKING THEN
ARE LYING TO YOU NOW.
SAME CAST OF CHARACTERS.
NOW, WE WILL BREAK THIS DOWN
IN DETAIL COMING UP.
AND, OF COURSE, JUST
BEGINNING TO SCRATCH THE
SURFACE OF JAMPACKED NEWS
CYCLE.
FAKE NEWS CNN THEY FOUND
TIME TO SPEND AN ENTIRE DAY
WHINING ABOUT REPUBLICAN
SENATOR MARTHA McSALLY.
HOW DARE SHE CALL ONE OF
THEIR REPORTERS A LIBERAL
HACK.
LIBERAL HACKS ONE IDIOT
CALLING IT A CHILLING
ATTACK.
MOB AND THE MEDIA, SO
SENSITIVE.
DEMOCRATIC ALLIES TRULY LIVE
IN THIS ALTERNATIVE RELATE.
BUCKLE UP.
BECAUSE WELL, IF THIS GET
THEIR WAY, WELL, IN THE COME
DAYS, ONLY GET WORSE.
IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS AHEAD,
THEY WANT TO DRAG THIS
COUNTRY THROUGH THE MUD AND
NOW THE PRESIDENT HAS A
CHANCE TO FIGHT BACK.
FINALLY.
HE HAS NOW ASSEMBLED THE
LEGAL TEAM TO REPRESENT HIS
CASE IN THE SENATE INCLUDING
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL PAT
CIPOLLONE, ALONG WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL
ATTORNEY, THAT WOULD BE JAY
SEKULOW FORMER INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL KEN STARR THAT LED
THE INVESTIGATION THAT LED
TO THE IMPEACHMENT OF FORMER
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON.
STARR IS JOINED BY FORMER
FLORIDA ATTORNEY GENERAL PAM
BONDI AND TWO OTHER
EXPERIENCED LAWYERS.
WE KNOW ABOUT ROBERT RAY AND
JANE RASKIN.
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALAN
DERSHOWITZ WILL PLAY A VITAL
ROLE LEADING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ORAL
ARGUMENTS AGAINST
IMPEACHMENT.
THE PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TIME
WILL EASILY DESTROY THE
DEMOCRATS' TWO BOGUS
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT
BECAUSE THIS ENTIRE
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE IS
NOTHING BUT A POLITICAL
SMEAR CAMPAIGN.
DEMOCRATS, WELL, THEY ARE
GOING TO TRY TO DRAG THE
TRIAL ON FOR AS LONG AS
HUMANLY POSSIBLE.
THEY WANT TO SLOW-WALK THIS
SHAM SCHIFF SHOW AND BUILD
THE INTENSITY AND INSANITY
SO THEY WILL HAVE A MAJOR
CRESCENDO OF CONSPIRATORIAL
DRAMA.
THEY WILL TRY TO ENTER INTO
EVIDENCE WELL, NEW THINGS.
THEY WILL TRY TO DEMAND THAT
NEW WITNESSES TESTIFY.
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO
DEMAND THAT NEW
INVESTIGATIONS, BASED ON NEW
EVIDENCE, MAGICALLY TURNS UP
AT THE LAST SECOND BE
INTRODUCED FROM THE GUY THAT
IS INDICTED.
THEY ARE GOING TO DO
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING TO
DERAIL THE PRESIDENT'S
FORTHCOMING ACQUITTAL.
BUT THEIR ACHILLES HEEL IS
NO OTHER THAN THIS GUY QUID
PRO QUO JOE AND OF COURSE
HIS SON ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER BIDEN WHO MADE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS FROM A CORRUPT
UKRAINIAN OIL AND GAS
COMPANY ALL WHILE HIS FATHER
WAS SPEARHEADING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S POLICY ON
UKRAINE.
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN EVEN
LEVERAGED A BILLION OF YOUR
TAX DOLLARS IN ORDER TO GET
A UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
FIRED, SON OF A B., HE DID.
WHY DID HE WANT THE
PROSECUTOR FIRED?
HE WAS INVESTIGATING HIS
ZERO-EXPERIENCED SON.
WHAT COMPANY WOULD EVER PAY
SOMEBODY MILLIONS IF THEY
HAVE ZERO EXPERIENCE?
NONE.
ANY OF YOU EVER GET THAT
DEAL?
NOW, THAT IS THE VERY REAL
CORRUPTION.
VERY CORE OF THIS
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE.
DEMOCRATS, YOU WANT TO DRAW
THIS OUT, GO DOWN THIS ROAD,
WELL, NOW IT BECOMES A VERY
DANGEROUS GAME.
AND THE SENATE IT NOW
OFFICIALLY THE NEW SCHIFF
SHAM SHOW.
AND BY THE WAY JUST LIKE THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION HOAX AND
THE KAVANAUGH SMEAR AND
EVERY OTHER CON JOB FROM THE
RADICAL LEFT THE